візит знайомства а на великих змін
так вугілля дачі називають пашу робочу
поїздку до України нового міністра за
кордонів з правими чини зігмар габріель
про-ве вдень вона вчить бути вони менше
підході в вони їх в мог до україни
mercy частини франк-вальтер штайнмаєр а
берлін чека та вид києва та Москви на сам
до 3 манія мінських на рік а сам і
становлення буде для початку
давши відривав його перемир'я далі засирати
дружині на реформах
очевидної е науки сьогодні продовження
боротьби з корупцією у ключі nazis
творенням антикорупційного суду
відразу всіх сус і річки був порубаний не так
сьогодні антикорупційні суть цієї
ключовий елемент
я колони в джерела тому на теми і
буду фокус інший акцент я думаю буду
трабла але на біляш масштабніший за судна
оправа віру формі готова шепоче та форми
проти дух відривали перспективі так
вже берлін будуть і сатана ви вирішите
проблем земельну реформу то
приватизацію дешкет спадкоємство що правда
ікон сама буду колір писк випромінювань з
берліна експорту право називатися наберу
team також наведені лицьового по фартуху
габріелі настільки сильно приймаєте
висловлюванням українських проблем додають
геть та windows знаєте вона всередину вже не
полетіть олл-іни dos шинки і за
зовнішньої політики як штайнмайєр у нього
nemo і такого упередженого інтерес ще
до роль анімацію середньої Європи
the stream його не і руси і біля району
такий бум штайнмайєра там у я гадаю для
габріеля харчування росії та україни будуть
значно меншим 3 цьому нижче для нього
папороті до штайнмайєр від бліх особи
з than харчування та переміщення кровний інтерес
вигляд новий ти світ в Україні та добрий вигляд
але сон з Росії вин дуже багато
виступів про норманський формат мінські
переговори води був інакше його гід шукаємо
більше зигмара габріеля називають біси
лояльним до Москви
ми спокій тисяч через з українцем на
роту agip елітку не міченим спочатку 1
по садово особливо а в ряд країни на голду
ці обряди ніж у крем того самого маршруту
пішаків без цих габріелів країни балтії та
Україна
та й привіт для оптимізму